we're getting a first look at how US
troops deployed to the southern border
are preparing for more than 5,000
migrants moving through southern Mexico
the closest member members of the
caravan are about 700 miles away from
the US and are not expected to arrive
for weeks
Matea via al is along the border in
Hidalgo Texas
Matea good morning well good morning
here along the Rio Grande River this is
one of the spots where migrants used to
cross into the US illegally but now
there is this barbed-wire fence it's
going to be used to actually fill the
gaps where there is no border wall it
was installed over the weekend by about
a hundred US military troops here in
southern Texas right now the Pentagon
says more than seven thousand US troops
are joining the nearly 2100 National
Guardsmen already assigned to the
southern border now people who live and
work in the Rio Grande Valley are split
though about the increased military
presence I believe that in your home you
should be safe and secure and when you
don't feel that yes you do want the
government to do something about it it's
a great big publicity stunt you think
that the president is using the military
absolutely he didn't get his parade so
he's trotted them out here there are
reports this border deployment could
cost upwards of 200 million dollars by
the end of the year and just to give you
some perspective I'm about 5-2 on a good
day this barbed wire fence stands about
four feet tall roughly it is sharp
however the reality is people can get
over this if they really watch the best
it can do it's probably slow somebody
down there is important perspective
Maria thank you interesting to get the
differing ideas and thoughts and
reaction all of that thank you